[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in the storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney hosted the doctor John
deloney show number one best-selling
author of the book own your past
change your future is my co-host today
as we talk about your life and your
money he has a brand new book coming out
called building a non-anxious life we
put it on sale pre-sale it comes out
technically October 3rd that's when
we'll ship them but it's on pre-sale
right now we're talking about it because
we're giving you a bunch of extra bonus
items to buy it now in other words we're
going to bribe you to buy it early and
it's working because thousands of people
have accepted the bribe hey I will take
it all all the way to the bookstore man
we'll bribe them away I'm telling you
building a non-anxious life
you know we there were so many subtitles
that are possible some of which are just
humorous but yeah but building a
non-anxious life in the most freaked out
stressed out anxious-filled culture in
the history of man that'd be a long
subtitle but yeah but that's really kind
of what we are right in the middle of
one of the worst weird times in human
history it doesn't make any sense until
you back out and say oh man we've just
created a world that our bodies can't
live in and the world's not going to
change it's going to keep going faster
and the only thing I can control is me
so I gotta do something different so I
think the premise that we that you
started talking about first was in
redefining anxieties is that anxiety is
not the problem it's the alarm going off
saying there's a problem that's right
and um I you know in that regard I love
you quoting one doc who says that um
I'll let you do it that that uh we saw
anxiety is actually your friend in that
regard yeah the the Dr Wendy Suzuki at
NYU she's brilliant she she says anxiety
is a friend exactly that is good it lets
you know hey your house on fire house on
fire which if your neighbor came and
banged on your door and said your your
Barn's on fire that's a good neighbor
right
um but man in a world where we want to
have it all without any consequences and
without any discomfort we all want it
all right now
um our body's just doing what it can to
get our attention man and we're all
rattling at the seams so in the six
daily choices covered in the book that
if you do these six daily choices that
include things like human connection
building relationships that that puts a
deposit in the bank building your uh
mental health emergency fund so that
when stuff comes at you you've got a
full tank and I think that's an
excellent word choice when because most
of us just pretend that at any moment we
can't get a flat tire or that a roof
will leak or you and I were just talking
offline I had a sewer issue last night
in the middle of the night with the
rainstorm
um I mean life I think I should say your
your house had a sewer issue I did not
I'm good the pipes are running right
speaking of word choices that's right
but it's not a matter of uh of of if
it's it will right I like to think of it
like this this is from our mutual friend
will guadera
if you if you look at your life like a
water glass
the lower you can keep that water in
your glass throughout a day when life
hits you and dumps a bunch of water you
can hold it you can hold it but if you
have a No Boundaries and a calendar that
runs your life and your elementary
school kids run your life and your
soccer coach tells you what you're doing
every weekend from here to the end of
Eternity and your mother-in-law's still
cooking dinner that's exactly right and
you owe a bank tells you what you're
going to do tomorrow and you're you have
to sit with an abusive boss your
marriage is a wreck and how many friends
your glass is already brimming and then
when that thing happens you scream at
people and you hit some no amount of
pharmaceuticals is going to make that go
away it it can no it it turns the noise
down it turns that alarm down so that I
can go meet with a counselor and a
pastor or say the things I need to say
to my wife so there is a time for
pharmaceuticals but if Pharmaceuticals
are only masking
the the alarm it's not actually giving
you you're not taking that opportunity
then to fix it yeah then it's kind of
like the student loans being on pause
and you don't go get them paid off while
they're on pause that's a that's a I
think that's a great that's a great uh
analogy there yeah you had this moment
for three years we have you had a chance
you had a chance you had a shot the
alarms are the alarms were turned down
you had a chance to get after it yeah
there was no uh interest so the problem
that uh you and people in the uh in the
field of mental health have with the
pharmaceutical idea is not that all farm
is bad it's not that you never need uh
some drugs to get things oriented it's
that when you try to use that instead of
actually fixing the problem there you go
that's right and so at the end of the
day
um uh there that we've all had that
moment where you climb up and just pull
the the little nine volt battery out of
your smoke detector because it
something's not calibrated it's just
going off all the time and you can pull
the battery out that's what medication
does right it pulls the battery out of
the alarm just stops IT the goal there
is to not not have a smoke detector
forever the goal is to fix the problem
right now
yeah so again six daily choices a
spiritual relational uh Financial
there's a whole series of them that's
not how he's got them labeled but it
will help you build a non-anxious life
so when an anxiety-inducing thing comes
at you you're much more prepared you've
got room in your glass to use wilgaras
uh now our metaphor then to do it the
book is building a non-anxious life you
can be done by Dr John deloney here's
the thing
you gotta get it it's only twenty
dollars and we're gonna throw in seventy
five dollars worth of items including
instant access to Dr delony's newest
talk smoke fire and freedom that breaks
down the mythology that we believe that
we believe about anxiety and will help
you start to reclaim your life right now
and when the book comes out in October
we'll also ship you not only the book
but the ebook the audiobook of building
a non-anxious life again we've sold
thousands of these already thank you
very much for your response we
appreciate you and uh so jump in there
and go ahead and get it today at
ramseysolutions.com and by the way if
you're a Dr deloni or a Ramsay fan or
both I'll let you know up front this
helps us because it helps the marketing
all of the sales prior to October 3rd
count in the October third week toward
the best seller list completely above
board legal everybody knows what we're
doing it's all fine pre-sales count in
that regard so the pre-sales help us a
bunch with the marketing and so if you
want to help us to go ahead and get it
now and we'll rob you to do it twenty
dollar book for twenty dollars and you
get seventy five dollars in free bonus
items going to
ramsesolutions.com building a
non-anxious life look at that guy does
he not look like he looks not anxious to
me other than his sewer problem but he
looks you know I think when we took his
house his house I was quite anxious I
think that's what I was realizing whoa I
need to code I need to start following
some of these things I'm teaching I need
to read this book this afternoon yeah
that'll do it that'll do it well
redefining anxiety the uh was a little
37-page uh kind of a chapter book we
call them quick reads here that we put
out and it sold 150 000 copies so I
predict that this uh it's one of the
things that led us to say hey John yeah
and you said yeah this is what we need
to do people need help in this area they
need guidance in this area they need
hope well I thought I I really thought
you know we I did redefine anxiety
during the middle of covet I I thought
that when the World opened backed up
we'd all saw each other go bananas and
we would
come together and the opposite has
proven true it's just we just started
throwing matches at all the gasoline
puddles and so it's it's a mess but I
love that you said that it's a book
about Hope man I am pretty optimistic
about what comes next absolutely
building a non-anxious life Dr John
deloney at ramsleysolutions.com hit the
store get the deal this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John baloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Luna is in Salt Lake City
Utah hi Luna welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
uh can you hear me all right yes
okay
um so I'm gonna try and make this as
short as possible but I'm 29. I have a
fire under my butt to go back to school
and I'm currently one year through you
know undergraduate it's going to be four
years so I'm it's going to be really a
useless degree unless I go to graduate
school because it's for a Veterinary
doctor degree
and I'm looking at it and it looks like
I'm going to be able to pay for it uh
you're gonna hate this it's going to be
all on loans but I don't even make over
like
the threshold to make
you know pay taxes
so I I make next to nothing my family
all live paycheck to paycheck but the
one Saving Grace here is like my
grandparents they have a trust and they
say that I have 10 of it
when they die and I'm wondering like
is it possible to borrow from a trust or
get it early or what what can I do
because I'm just looking to pay for my
living expenses through college
what were you doing before you went on
this adventure
um
but
it's kind of left
but who's saying your husband your kids
yes
I don't have any kids I've got cats but
um
yeah I
I was married for a short time divorced
but um
my life kind of fell apart for a while
and I put it back together and I finally
have like a passion and a purpose and
I'm like I said I've got a fire under my
butt to go back to school and make
something of myself
but I'm just you know there's there's
not a lot of money out there for
students unless you borrow and that's
not a good option but can I challenge
something can I challenge something real
quick
yeah
um you don't gotta go make something of
yourself you already got worth right now
yeah okay
and you got I think that fire under your
butt honestly is how burned you are
because you looked at somebody and you
said I do and he said I do and then he
left
well I mean that's that's not something
that I'm really focusing on here in the
future that's kind of
pass has passed but now like this pastor
chip just so caught up in your throat
you can hardly speak that's right
there's a great quote that says you may
be through the past but the past isn't
through with you and if you don't heal
from that where you can talk about it
and think about it without your body
getting overcome then it's gonna haunt
you and what it's going to do it's gonna
shoot you like a rocket ship into some
life-altering decisions like getting 250
or 300 000 in the hole
and not knowing what what what day what
what direction is up or down
and maybe not even finishing
and getting the DVM that's right not
everybody that starts vet school
finishes vet school not everybody that
finishes vet school passes their boards
and becomes a veterinarian
and so
um it's harder than medical schools from
what I think it is one of my friends
this event says when you're in medical
school you only have to learn one set of
anatomy he said I have to learn a whole
bunch of them so he makes fun of doctors
and it's very difficult and uh
intellectually difficult and uh and you
love animals obviously and becomes an
emotional process too so Luna the answer
to your question is no you cannot borrow
on a trust unless the trust has uh
written into it the uh that option I'm
gonna bet you that this one does not
and can they release who is the trust
your grandparents formed the trust for
their money to leave to their grandkids
if their grandkids and their children
yeah okay and how much is in the trust
um
I think it was down a little bit right
now but it was like 2.7 million dollars
so your parts like 270 000 so it would
fund you going to school okay so if you
talk to your grandfather he could just
choose to take you out of the trust
and take 270 000 and pay for your school
and you no longer would be in the trust
okay uh he could choose to do that
legally uh you want me to tell you what
I think is going to happen you're not
going to like it
grandfather loves you I think your
grandfather loves you and he's going to
see how fragile you are and that you're
probably not in really good emotional
shape right now to go take on something
like the Battle of vet school
it's going to take a lot more strength
than you've exhibited in this call to do
that and I'm not picking on you honey I
think you've been hurt
and you're still hurting and I want you
to have some healing and be going at vet
school from strength rather than from
weakness and I got a feeling your
grandpa might say that does that sound
like something he might say
and maybe but I also skipped over the
part where I went to like therapy and I
was in the hospital for a while doing
inpatient and outpatient like and and
here's the thing here's the thing
sweetie I I'm pretty well balanced now
I've been a I've I've been a I've taught
doctoral students I've walked them
through their dissertation I've worked
with law students I've worked with
medical students like
I need you to hear what Dave's saying
that probably the greatest gift you
could give yourself is to get a one if
not two jobs where you are working
really close with animals because it's
what you love
um and do that hour in hour out day
after day week after week month after
month and make sure you love this and
for two or three years and let yourself
have some distance because
um the lady we're talking to is having
trouble going through the conversation
much less through three years of vet
school
and this is two guys who both love our
dogs and we love great vets we want you
to win I want you to win I'm not trying
to be a dream killer I'm trying to be a
nightmare killer yeah and I got a
feeling if your Grandpa loves you and if
he's wise he will deny your request
not because he's being mean but because
he's going to hear and see what we're
hearing and seeing that's my guess now
again you're just a radio show we've
only talked to you for two minutes honey
but you sound very hurt and very fresh
and very raw and talking to you and
that's not a that's not saying you
haven't done hard work already but
you've got some more you've got some
more healing to do is what it sounds
like and if we're wrong we're wrong you
go do what you want to do honey uh
you're a grown-up you're allowed to do
what you want to do you called us and
we're going to tell you the truth
because we love you here's a here even
if it's not what you want to hear I'm
going to give you this analogy
um I've met with countless people over
the years who are sick and tired of
being overweight
and they say today is the day like that
I start
none of those folks are going to be
successful if the next day they start
running a marathon that's not how that
works
they start walking around their
neighborhood they hire a personal
trainer and slowly start lifting weights
it's a slow gradual process it's going
to take time because you have to heal
you have to change your entire way of
doing life and to build your muscle tone
that's right you got to build your body
and so
um I want you to hear me a day save say
later not now yeah this is not easy not
never not right now not right now and
you're going to know a whole lot more
about you and a whole lot more about
this career path if you'll go do what
John said and that's become a vet tech
and just go in there and love animals
every day and get paid and pay your
bills and get paid and love animals and
pay your bills and get paid and smile
and get in the morning read your Bible
and sit on the back porch with a cup of
coffee and watch the sun come up and
know that everything's going to be okay
and you do that a little while longer
and you know the past will be a little
bit more in your rearview mirror and
again I'm not discounting
putting down all the work you've done so
far the hospital the therapists all that
I'm just telling you reflecting back to
you what we heard in three minutes on
the radio honey and I got a buddy about
as gentle as I know how to be yeah yeah
everyone who runs a vet clinic and he's
always talking about they're trying to
hire good vets and so I can even see a
scenario where you are a vet tech for a
couple years and some vet looks at you
and says I'll help you go through school
I'll pay for it if um you sign a
five-year deal with me or something and
so yeah man you may figure something out
there ding ding and the situation might
change with the trust over time if your
grandparents passed the 10 could be
coming to you while you're doing all of
this instead of you going up to your
eyeballs in debt in this situation and
then maybe not able to play through this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Patrick is on the line in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Patrick how
are you
how are you better than we deserve
what's up
yeah so uh just a quick question
um you know I I found you guys uh pretty
recently actually and and let me tell
you I mean I've been going through the
Rabbit Hole uh just watching videos and
and uh you know really just trying to
take charge of my debt well thank you
I'm glad we could help
yeah I mean absolutely and so my
question
um you know my wife and I we we already
discussed our plan we did
um you know all of our expenses in now
our remainder everything like that
um I'm at the point in my career where
I'm looking to kind of jump ship and uh
we're gonna get through baby step super
quick and just move you know on to on to
baby step two afterwards
um
should I be concerned at all with
transferring transitioning into another
job uh during that phase where we're
supposed to be paying off a lot of debt
or is that something that you know just
kind of comes with the process
well if you make more money
and there's not a gap
is nothing but upside to changing jobs
right
yeah
um and and that is true now you know I
work in IP um specifically doing you
know like QA work
um a lot of those jobs are typically
contract so they might not go past you
know three or six months but you don't
you're doing contract now
I am but this has been going on for over
three and a half years why would you
change you really don't see them drop
how would you change from contract to
contract
uh just for pay increase
okay can you get a pay increase becoming
a full-time team member instead of
contract
it depends I mean it really goes I think
based off of the company and their needs
at the time sure what do you make now
yeah
right now I'm making 72.5 okay
and if you took another contract it just
might not be as stable a contract is
that what you're saying
exactly yeah so I mean you know it could
could be three months six months there's
always the potential let's say you run
six months how hard is it to get the
next gig
that really all depends I haven't been
in that um I haven't been in that
situation uh you know the market
probably not too hard that's what I'm
thinking I mean we are a big Financial
uh Capital so there isn't a shortage of
work exactly
and and also a possibility is this but
would I just jump ship no I mean if you
took a contract that you're 90 sure is
not going to renew but it pays a little
more and it's a three-month contract no
I wouldn't take that
if I take something that pays for double
and I can lock it in for six months we
think it's probably going to renew I'm
taking that one
right that's how I'm looking at is this
making sense
just kind of use some common sense
analysis oh and by the way the third
option is get a job that pays double
and then we don't have to worry about
either we got double and we got we got
stability hypothetically right right
right right yeah that's yeah I mean the
way my company does it right now at the
moment is not your company your
contractor me and the
say again not your company you're a
contractor
that kind of is their company model so
it's an indian-based tech company and
they we work as clients to other people
yeah and they're the ones that kind of
manage the contract
yeah their their model is they don't
have to depend on you don't you can't
depend on them that's their model
okay exactly what that is and hey it's
it's really common dude to uh for people
who
are new to the gang and good on the
rabbit holes
that you start to see things that you've
done wrong with money or that you you
realize that you are contributing to the
the chaos in your home and one of the un
uh foreseen results of that is you lose
trust in yourself and you start to
wonder well should I do this and should
I do this so go back and just ask
yourself the question should I just quit
my job would that make me worried well
if you don't have any money yes that'd
make me worried if like Dave said if the
contract is up in three weeks yeah that
made me worried if it's changing for a
great job or a six-month job which is
that's pretty far out there for a tech
cool man I so just trust yourself even
though you've made some mistakes of
money trust yourself you know the beauty
of where you are is you have realized
something even though you don't realize
you realized it is that your only
security is your ability to land on your
feet if something happens meaning you're
in a wonderful field that is very hot
and you should be able to land something
and that's great security so your
security is not artificially some my
company is a big wonderful company that
doesn't mean squat if they fire your
butt tomorrow so your security is really
based in you right and you've already
figured that out sorta and that's where
your security is so it's not in the it's
not in the length of the contract but
you use that to say hey it's a wonderful
Market I'm in a wonderful field I could
make some more money I'm going to do
that in a wise way
and that's where you need to go with
this Stephen is with us in Knoxville hi
Stephen welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave hey
I've got a question uh regarding CDs and
money markets and paying down mortgage
uh me and my wife were debt free except
for mortgage and we like to pay down a
little bit uh every year but with the CD
and money market rates at like five five
and a quarter our mortgage rate is at
2.75 and I want to see if it's okay to
have money in in CDs and money markets
versus paying down at this time
well it's not illegal it's certainly
okay
um what what do you how much is your
mortgage
uh we have about 95 000 left on it okay
and so all this gyration is making you
two grand
yeah whoopee
you're near you're not getting rich
I wouldn't do all this crap for two
grand
you see other money in the bank to write
a check and pay off your mortgage right
uh close I'd do that today what are you
doing man pay your house off I would do
that today and if you hate having if you
hate being rid of your mortgage you can
go get you another one when interest
rates come down here's what I promise
you
if you look at the money that Americans
spend on sleep medications
it's way more than two thousand dollars
and I'd be willing to bet if you owe
nobody anything at all your brain
realizes that nobody can come take your
house
you will have a sleep that you didn't
know was possible you take your shoes
off walk through the backyard the grass
feels different dude
for two grand man all you know all day
you know if you told me you were making
fifty sixty thousand bucks doing this or
something we'd talk about it but for two
grand that's just comical no you're not
exactly arbitraging something here I
mean come on pay your house off man do
it right away right yesterday that's why
we call them certificates of
depreciation
CDs let me tell you the number of
millionaires that we meet they became
millionaires because of their CDs
precisely zero
precisely zero I've heard that in my
life ever I mean really now my grandpa
because he was a child I mean he lost
everything in the Great Depression and
started how to start over got a job at
alcohol aluminum worked there 38 years
and he would straighten the nail out
when you pull it out of a board and keep
it in a coffee can he was cheap as cheap
as cheap good Scott's Irish man cheaper
and cheap and uh
you know what he wasn't putting any
money in any stock market I can tell you
that he wasn't putting any money in any
mutual fund it was in a coffee can or it
was in a CD and some of the cities were
17 back in the day well but that doesn't
matter I'll guarantee you but he did
have over a million dollars but it not
because he earned anything on it but
just because he put that much in there
it didn't go away that's all it was it
wasn't like like it got like the
compound interest worked in his favor
because there wasn't much interest in
there wasn't much compound you know so
it just yeah but you can't argue with
the result but uh yeah you can do that
if you want to do it but I wouldn't do
it I would for two grand I wouldn't be
playing this game it's amazing the games
we play and the risk we take uh without
actually acknowledging it
and when you actually run the nominal
the actual dollar bills out not the
percentages it sounds so unsophisticated
when you run it out with the dollars my
friends in the nutrition space
um say it's stepping over a dollar to
pick up a dime or major in the miners
it's like man just Just Eat Right and
exercise it's like yeah no but what
about this special diet what about this
pill I'm just gonna eat this cat food
and you can take witch hazel and do a
little dance just exercise and eat
healthy food man yeah I know but what
about yeah what about what about don't
eat seven Big Macs pay your house oh
there's that your house off oh darn get
your house off can't take it take a pill
to get out of debt called deadenol this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
so our producer James went through the
archives and a thousand years ago when
Blake Thompson was producing this show
he actually did a comedy bit on detonal
uh John thought I made that up just a
few minutes ago and I couldn't take
credit for it because actually Blake
made it up and James found the old
comedy bit do you have any does he have
a date on it
it doesn't but I I would it's got to be
20 plus years yeah it's over 20 years
ago easy it was before there was color
on TV
all right here's from from over 20 years
ago what the uh the Ramsey Show uh then
called the Dave Ramsey Show might have
sounded like
nationally syndicated talk radio host
Dave Ramsey has often said that there is
no magic pill for getting out of debt
well sorry Mr Ramsey but there is and
it's called Dental
is a 100 all-natural drug that is
guaranteed to control your spending and
control your desire to overspend one
pill a day and you will no longer feel
the need to spend money you don't have
we have created this drug because we
care about you dentinol the pill that
cares minor side effects may include
fatigue
headache my head nervousness sore throat
explosive diarrhea insomnia I can't
sleep drowsiness I can't stay away
horrible nightmares oh gastronomical
trauma oh my hallucinations that rabbit
just said my name chronic halitosis a
slight cough and a runny nose dentinol
brought to you by the credit card
Association of America credit the easy
way oh the show used to be so good Dave
what happened
well we brought on co-hosts
got rid of Blake
the good old days he used to walk uphill
both ways in the snow yeah that was
probably done on a cassette tape
actually I'm trying to think I know the
well the voice on the uh disclaimer is
Blake the other voice what I think was
Phil Hampton is Bill Hampton is it okay
so yeah that's
it's over 20 years then yeah it might be
25 years old yeah that's funny I don't
care who you are still still works
though it's Timeless Timeless all right
we'll have five orders on the Ramsay
solutions.com
hell you guys were advertising Jordan is
in Los Angeles hi Jordan how are you
I'm doing well Dave thank you how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up
uh yeah so I just have a couple
questions because I'm in just like a
constant Financial Panic anxiety worry a
lot of is stemming from the environment
outside of me
um I can go into some numbers with
everything from personally in a bit I'll
give you a little background so I I had
like a I did have a lot of early success
in my late teens uh early 20s I'm now 27
um within the entertainment industry and
also just working my my butt off I've
always been a good saver
um and then
unfortunately covet hit which shut down
my every my little role I had going on
and then also at the same time I came
down with a with a pretty severe
debilitating
um underlying disease of Cushing's
Disease uh lupus and rheumatoid
arthritis uh that has developed
throughout the years so
um all of that has just led me to think
that what is my future going to look
like because it's very hard for me to do
physical labor
um my work right now is pretty limited
um and I've just been stuck in this rut
of I don't want to I'm anxious to when I
have to spend something as small as like
putting 20 bucks in for gas all the way
up to my rent I'm just living in this
fear and panic for my future and I've
been trying to think of an income stream
because of my ailments it makes it very
difficult and I've caused myself going
so that's what's frustrating because my
body is holding me back I have like that
entrepreneur mindset but I just don't
know what it is for me Jordan how do you
think we can best help you today son
um I I don't know how to manage what to
do with the money I currently have okay
um what how much money do you currently
have
so I have I'm Incorporated I
Incorporated when I was younger after I
got a pretty nice job
um I have a uh in my business checking
right now I have uh about twenty four
thousand five hundred I opened up a
business CD which has about 92 000 in
there I have a checking account of 8 000
right now I have a savings account of
fifty two thousand five hundred I have a
checking CD of forty thousand six
hundred
um I have I I I did have I wasn't a
mutual fund when I was younger and there
was some issues with the the accountant
who was advising it um and so those got
liquidated and
during my time when I was young of
course I just watched a bunch of videos
and of course I bought a bunch of
precious metals with a lot of that how
much is that
I have about 40 ounces of gold and 900
ounces of silver which I believe right
now is close to 100 a hundred thousand
dollars total okay and you've got about
400 000 bucks are you making any money
currently and I do also have I opened up
a robo advisor in Schwab recently
because I just felt like I was just
doing nothing with my money so yeah do
you have a house man where do you live I
I do I live in Los Angeles I'm still
renting
um do you have an income
yeah nobody's working yeah yeah
oh yeah
I would be willing to bet just just
friend to friend
you struggle with anxiety when you were
younger right
I started in my late scenes yes what's
the first time you remember that that
that your body kind of took off on you
and it scared you
uh in terms of my health or my anxiety
both because they work together um
the the yellow uh about 20 year 19 19
years old my anxiety took off my health
ailments kicked in a couple years later
yeah and that's and and and again I
don't want to get over my skis here in
this this we could talk for hours on it
but a autoimmune body is a body that is
so red lined out that it's been trying
to shut you down for a long time and it
will find another way to shut you down
right because it's tired of it's tired
of fighting and swinging and running
from everything
and that's what you just described right
and when you struggle with anxiety as a
younger kid it sometimes looks different
than it does when you're an adult but
then when you take that angst and then
you go put it up on a stage or on a
screen and all those voices telling you
what how to look and what stand and what
you shouldn't do and where you should go
man that's just a uh that's like taking
a blender and putting it inside of a you
know a jet engine right and spinning
that sucker up and it doesn't surprise
me hey that you've been very very
successful because you're clearly
brilliant and you have been able to keep
some of the anxiety demons at bay
through achievement accomplishment in
attaboys and it also doesn't surprise me
that your body said I'm shutting you I'm
shutting you down I caught up with you
yeah
does that sound familiar
oh very it's very frustrating because
again I I will work and do whatever I
have to do and right now here's what's
important I don't think you're afraid of
work yeah no you were Dave's gonna talk
to you about the money I want you to
know that if Dave if you follow Dave's
steps and clean up all your money and
that's all you do
you're gonna go with you on that Journey
and you're gonna have cleaned up money
and you're gonna have an ounce of
security there
and then your brain's gonna LeapFrog to
the next thing and you know that right
because it's been a leapfrogging on you
for years yeah so what what you've you
you while you've been an incredible
income earner
and it's apparent that you've done
something that uh had incredible talent
because people paid you a lot of money
for it uh so uh what you'd never had in
any of these situations is a sense of
control
you didn't feel like you're you felt
like ever even though you had a big old
pile of money you still didn't feel like
it was all in control and it still today
doesn't feel like it's in control so I
think there's probably a two-pronged
approach here and that would be you
called on the perfect day with Dr John
deloney here is
um you're getting a sense of control in
your life a sense of uh the chaos pushed
back and you choosing to set up really
firm boundaries with a whole bunch of
things to say this is what I do this is
what I don't do this is what I do this
is what I don't do and you've got some
very clear kind of a black and white
type response to everything because
you're
a creative brain allows you to work out
about 73 scenarios simultaneously
instead of yes or no and you just need
to get real simplified and go to yes or
no and so no we don't do precious metals
let's go ahead and cash those out and
get those Into Cash no uh we don't walk
around with no income so let's try to
figure out something we can put our hand
to
um yes we're going to send you a book
called own your past change your future
from Dr John deloney read through that
because there's a whole lot of what's
going on in that book is going on with
you we'll send a building on exercise
too I think that would be a good vote
for him can we get it out of here yeah
okay good let's send them both of those
and throw in a Total Money Makeover book
we'll help you with the money part too
but you it's controlling the
controllables that's going to get this
moving this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love The
Show
or dive on your
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way just go
to ramseysolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book own your
past change your future and the new book
coming out building a non-anxious life
he hosts the Dr John deloney show on the
Ramsay network if you've not heard it
you should tune in it is a highly
popular podcast YouTube show that is
exploding because he helps people with
relationships with mental health things
with boundaries with all the things that
people do it's uh sometimes very serious
sometimes very fun and you always will
learn something the phone number here if
you want life and money is easy it's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Samantha is in Kansas City hi
Samantha how are you
I'm doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up
I just lost my husband around about
146 days ago wow he took his wife oh no
our home oh no and I
yes how old was he
uh 52. what was his name Samantha
John John
I'm so sorry man
thank you wow
you have children
yes what age
um my son is 23 he's an engineer and my
daughter is 25 uh she's a nurse
are they in the area
yes we are all very close good good I'm
so sorry how long were you married
um 26 years together 27.
what's on my man
I can't I'm so sorry
wow how can we help darling
well
I am trying to
um
figure out if I am worthy enough to move
could carry any more
if it would help me with the guilt
and if I can afford it
I think that I can
um I just need an outside neutral person
to
lock me through it
tell me about the word worthy what do
you mean
anytime that
someone
finds their significant other or a
family member something of that nature
um
in that fashion
that there's always guilt the eager that
you carry
without there's a big burden to bears
and so
you start to feel extremely stuck
and you feel like if you leave the place
that you were
together that your disrespecting
that person
and I've tried every day to
respect him I write to him
I sing to him I talk to him
and so
I'm very isolated because my
my children panic when they come here my
parents don't want to come here and I
have this really
interesting relationship with my home
but I also know that I need to leave it
to move forward with my life it's just
going to be I completely agree yeah can
I can I be super super difficult can I
be super direct with you is that okay
absolutely okay
um thing number one I don't ever want
you to ask the question am I worthy
again
got it okay answer's yes
okay okay answer number I'm going to
tell you a quick little aside
um about a year ago I was cleaning out a
closet upstairs and I do this every
couple of years and there was a tweed
jacket that my granddad gave me one of
the greatest men I've ever met
and it has never fit and he passed away
a couple years ago
and I remembered him I laughed a little
bit because he had a funny thing he
always did and then I put it in the keep
pile and as I set it down I immediately
picked it back up and I held it
then I put my fist in my chest God all
mine I'm getting choked up again
and I said out loud by myself
my granddad is not in this jacket he's
right here in my chest
I need you to hear me say your husband
is not in that home
he is in your heart
and that's where he's going to be and
did that man love you
I hope so I'm gonna tell you right now
he loved you to the end of the Moon
and he probably got sideways in his own
mind and thought he was doing everybody
a favor
right
I agree
and so what I want you to hear me say is
the greatest
way to honor him
is that you go be well
and being in that home where you can't I
don't have access to your family where
you don't have access to yourself you
don't have access to your your kids is
not
helping you be whole every time you walk
down the hall
and you you see it all again you've seen
stuff that nobody should see I've been
in those homes in the middle of the
night yeah you saw it and it stamped
itself on your heart yeah I suggest if
you're my sister I would tell you to
move out of the house if you're my mom I
would tell you move out of that house
move out of that house
okay
what will that sell for
um 420 14 or more okay um and what what
do you own what do you own what do you
owe on it nothing nothing
okay and you live in Kansas followed
your plan okay so Samantha you have 420
000 to go buy a house
okay okay or if you want to rent for six
months and cry
and then buy a house oh I think I've
done enough of that well you got 100 you
only have 146 days of it so far but yeah
you're not you're not done and when you
sell this house quote the lady I'm
talking to it'll be hard right yeah if
I'm you
um emotionally spiritually financially
everything your best shot at healing and
putting this horrible tragedy in the
rear view mirror not forgetting him but
putting the thing in the rearview mirror
and living into your future not living
into your past is to not have to walk
down that Hall again and see that image
in your mind every time you walk down
the hall am I wrong right
no no I would put a call uh go to
ramseysolutions.com get a real estate
ELP
tell them what happened tell them what's
going on and tell them put the house on
the market by Saturday I want you out of
there
okay and I want you to tell you how's
that feel yeah when I said that yeah
and um I'm debt free you are you are
that's now I'm calling you are and
you're about to have a whole different
level of Freedom right now and it's not
going to be
um dishonoring yeah
and life is not to run a museum
that's not your call it feels like a
museum
it's both it is it is all of the above
and it's time for you to go turn the
lights on somewhere else and live I want
you to call your kids and say hey I'm
about to go through it we're going to
have some joy and we're gonna have some
help and I want y'all with me y'all come
over here and get what you want because
I'm getting ready to shovel this stuff
into the dumpster in the back and we're
leaving yeah that's you know get a
construction dumpster out there and fill
it up but I want you to look in the
mirror and I want you to put your hand
on your chest I want you to say out loud
John is here he's not in this house he's
not in this hallway he's not in these
walls he's here in your heart and it's
time for me to go
good
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality opened
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five thank you for joining
us he's my co-host today
[Applause]
I don't I don't think you can walk away
from that last call without kind of
unpacking a little bit and just keep
going and talk to somebody about their
401k or something so I'm not going to um
and I don't know exactly what to do with
it other than it's just a heavy thing a
heavy call for her to start this hour
out with to her to call and say 146 days
ago my husband took his own life in this
home do I sell this home uh there's so
many different
elements of that
um
one of the things we dealt with during
the the uh the fauci quarantine was
non-essential workers essential workers
the the the uh the uh the suicide rate
during the covid
craziness
um that's being kind
um the suicide rate was great what was
out of control just the lack of I don't
have any worth I don't have any purpose
no value you tell people they're not
essential you send them home you trap
them without contact other humans and
then you watch the suicide rate go up
and uh that wasn't his case obviously
because this was just 146 days ago but
the you that got us on this show and on
your show talking a lot about uh people
considering uh taking their own lives
and and just reminding people don't yeah
that was an important talk to somebody
for God's sakes that was an important
thing this I that I ran across years ago
in grad school was this idea that
how many people end up taking their life
because they think they're helping other
people out this side this it's called
perceived they'll be better off everyone
which is the world will be better off
yeah and it becomes this altruistic
um thing Dave and I can't tell you the
number of of suicide scenes I showed up
to
there was so much thought and Care put
into the act of taking your life so that
those coming after
won't be bothered by it and I thought if
you the amount of love and care you're
putting into this if you could just see
that that's how they feel about you
right and so man it's uh if you do feel
that please please please please call
somebody and on the other side I think
with that last call or something that
you called out Dave those moments get
baked into our nervous system and often
a change of environment however hard
that is it's really important because
your body puts a GPS pin in this place
in those images and that night and
um as painful as it can be sometimes a
change of scenery is really critical you
know I hadn't thought about that but you
know I was had this experience last
night Sharon I went to dinner in
downtown Nashville which is about a 30
minute drive for a 40-minute drive from
here and um but I grew up in Nashville
my whole life I've been here so 60 years
I've been in this town so
I drive past certain intersections exits
um go down a certain stretch of a
certain Road
and I completely
remember joyful things
sorrowful things that there's a GPS
stamped in those things that's right I
never thought about that and did what
happened last night we're driving past
this exit and I went I remember that guy
used to live up there he was a good old
guy more fun but you probably was
awesome memory in that case sometimes I
remember that guy's up there and he's a
twerp and I remember that too but yeah
what I what I remember is driving past
the intersection where I had a wreck
yeah oh I find myself gripping the
steering wheel a little bit tighter
without even thinking about it oh and uh
it's this extra level of control and
it's it's it's beautiful how the body
works I didn't even think about it but
my body remembered that one I was 16
years old driving to Green Hills on
Harding Place to pay off my car going to
the bank
and I hit a guy and tore the front out
of my car
he slammed on his brakes in front of me
it was raining I slammed on my brakes I
was driving too fast I was 16. and I hit
the back bumper of this truck and tore
the whole front off my car getting ready
to go pay for it I can definitely show
you where that was yeah and I that was I
was 16 I'm 62. but if you and I were
just driving on your rafter just chit
chatting I'm trying to see you and I
don't drive past that without you right
your body keeps the score it remembers
that's 50 or 40 years ago yeah that's
wild that's that's I never thought of
that and listening to her talk about her
kids like kids saying I can't go into
that house yeah absolutely and of course
they can they're tied into that that
body and that guilt when somebody that
you love
um dies by Suicide that you have that
yeah yeah not you yeah so much pain and
tragedy around that particular type of
loss yeah yeah so for God's sakes if you
we've talked about this during covet a
lot if you're struggling with those
kinds of thoughts the a the world's not
better off without you B talk to someone
now and let me say a c and this is
counterintuitive what I'm about to say
um there's a great researcher who
studied folks who jumped off the Golden
Gate Bridge which is one of the
epicenters of of geographical locations
jump who talk to people who jumped and
lived and when they did because because
I would think
if I intervene if I say something if I
get in somebody's business when I find
out they're considering taking their
their lifetime by Suicide
um they're just going to find another
way to do it and what they found is
those that jumped and lived
a vast High 90 percent went on to live a
long life yeah and so it would not try
again it was this moment like if you
will intervene
it can be different from here on out
yeah right so if you know of some don't
my friends and family know deloney will
get in your business right yeah there's
no no holds barred once you say that
game on baby I'll call him well you
can't tell anybody tough I will I'm
telling you yeah I'd rather you be alive
five years from now and hate me than not
be here I'm definitely going to let you
be pissed I can handle that all day long
I'm gonna all day long count on me
telling somebody yep yeah just count on
it count on me throwing flares up
calling 9-1-1 whatever it is because
we're going to make sure that because we
care about you and other people do too
so that that's the thing open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five Evan is in Boston hi Evan
how are you
I'm good how are you doing today Mr
Ramsey better than I deserve how can I
help
well currently
um at my stance in life I'd like to
diversify my portfolio a bit better
because I feel like I probably have the
ratio is a bit wrong and as I tread
leaving my um college degree probably be
my best interest to get the foundation
started before I end up continuing my
career
okay so what's your investments in
uh currently I have 30
000 in stock uh just in The Brokerage
and then I have another 15 000 in a Roth
IRA and I started a few years back
that's why the contributions aren't as
high and then I just have five grand
sitting in a checking account
okay I don't think anything to worry
about uh much except your stock
and obviously single stocks are less
Diversified
uh than a good growth stock mutual fund
that's why I don't buy them I buy good
growth stock mutual funds and that same
thirty thousand instead of being in five
or six seven stocks will be in 290 to
um which will give you a lot more safety
so I would definitely do that and make
sure that your Roth IRA is in a good
growth stock mutual fund as well spread
out but
um that's your foundation and then do
you have any debt
no good I don't have any and so you said
you graduating from school right
yeah what's your degree
my degree is currently financing
corporate Investments okay when you
start your new job
well the job I'm still not done I'm just
now starting my senior year I'm still
debating on whether or not I want to go
for my masters okay and what's nice is
Walmart uh covers all that uh fees so
I'm sorry you're working for Walmart so
they're paying for your masters
yeah one thing with Walmart that's kind
of uninteresting is you don't have to be
there for a certain amount of time you
can walk in on day one and as long as
your major is supported your books and
your tuition are fully covered by them
as long as you work okay
and uh why do you want to get a masters
I'm I assume you mean an MBA
yeah
um I'm the only reason would be to just
extend my knowledge even further I'm a
very analytical guy and I wouldn't want
to leave anything on the table that
would help me in a deer situation oh
you're definitely gonna leave some
things on the table 100 dude and
sometimes the most analytical guys what
they really need is real life
um on the floor trading experience yeah
so I I'm okay with getting an MBA uh
getting one just because you want to
collect knowledge probably not
um it's okay but um getting one because
you've been in some street fights and
some business deals and then you want to
learn some more that makes more sense
yeah I I if you if Walmart's paying for
it you want to go do it that's fine but
you don't have to have that to be
complete I'll tell you that working at
Walmart will give you some lessons there
it is
probably that's wrong this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here if you like the show you can
help us by subscribing click follow
click like click subscribe whatever the
particular
platform or format you're listening or
watching the show on tell people about
where you're hearing the show talk radio
or watching on TBN whatever it is you're
doing thank you so share click the share
button some of these things have a share
button and you can just send it to your
buddy that's cool that's all that stuff
helps us immensely because you're
basically our marketing budget that's
how much we think of you so there you go
oh and by the way leave a five star
review we'd love that too thank you all
right Max is with us in Detroit hey Max
what's up
better than I deserve how can I help
okay
and my mother I had last year my dad
caught um he got sicko he had got lung
cancer so I live in Michigan so I had
been traveling back and forth taking
care of my mom and my dad through the
chemo and just passed of last January he
just passed away
um she didn't really oh thank you she
did really good in the stock market but
when he got sick we didn't realize till
after the death that so much money had
been lost through the Investments okay
so I put her back with my aunties and
then back in Chicago that's where
originally were from Once has you know
kind of passed you know the healing time
a little bit it's kind of easy but she's
been really on me about moving her back
to Florida and just quitting my job and
just taking care of her
okay so you talked about a series of
Investments sir is there a lot of money
that your parents had
well you know what we when we started
when my dad was talking to me we was at
about 7 25 but now we're down to 400.
wow they do have a
because no one took care of the stock
market when he got sick the stock market
hadn't gone in half
well whatever Investments he had it went
down no one took care of it he was the
owner who's taking care of it now
my cousin's been took place of it
because he's the only one that really
kind of was investing in the family
why is your cousin taking care of your
and your mother's money yeah Max this is
money's gonna be gone overnight in a
vapor
the stuff in investing and kind of how
old is your mother
uh 86 yeah
we still have the house in Florida
but the thing was I mean you live in
Detroit what do you do for a living
oh I was I want see now
do you want to live in Florida
actually go to Texas where my children I
have all grown children and grandbabies
and my ultimate goal was getting back to
Texas and then this had happened to my
dad and now my mom is by herself I'm an
only child so here's what your mom used
to do she used to call Nick
and get her money
and she needs to sit down with you and a
good investment broker and put her money
to work the money that the 400 000 will
earn for an 86 year old can hire her
someone to help her to help take care of
her
I could that's what she needs to do and
that's not you
that's no then that's what I feel
sometimes but then the whole family is
like the only person I don't care what
the whole family they don't get us facts
doesn't want to go they don't get a vote
Max now if your mom wants to move with
you to Texas then you can lay that out
and say I'm happy to have you come move
in with me in Texas and we'll hire some
skilled nursing or whatever we need it
at the house I don't know what taking
care of her means
but Max this all these people telling
you what to do living their life getting
to use you like like a Nintendo joystick
they don't get to do that it's not their
life they don't get a vote
I feel bad
why
'd you do what you're doing wrong child
what'd you do wrong but if you invite
your mom to Michigan you've been taking
care of your mom you've been taking care
of your dad your appearance of dreams
they didn't want to just right they
didn't want to go to Michigan when I
said let's go to Michigan but that's
where their dog lives their choice if
they want me to take care of them they
have to come where I am yeah she's a
grown-up
she gets to make adult decisions she
does not get to dictate to you anymore
with her mother voice you are like a
grown person and she's an 86 year old
old woman
right
and she is trust me Dave and I talk to
enough people she is beyond the Moon
that she has raised a daughter with
Integrity who cares about her family and
loves her mom enough to have walked
alongside her as she lost her husband
and you lost your dad that's amazing
yeah
but so I want to give you a line okay my
mother your mother tells you what to do
by throwing out guilt trips she's a
travel agent for guilt trips isn't she
yes it works all right I want you to do
this why I'm taking the plane with it
when she drops it on me I take the plane
with it and I'm like oh why don't you
why don't you just why don't you say
it's not gonna work anymore
I have to get over that part all right
Max I'm gonna give you a line and I want
you to tattoo it on your heart okay
okay this is not my line it I don't
remember who came up with it but here's
what it is
I want you to choose guilt over
resentment every time
because if you don't choose guilt
over resentment
you are going to end up hating your mom
that she took away moments with your
grandbabies from you and that's not fair
to her that's not fair to you
right and so I'd rather feel guilty that
hey I want to be with my kids and my
grandbabies and I want their great
grandma with them but she's a grown
woman if she chooses Florida over all
that then she chooses afford over all
that
yeah she gets to choose
okay as long as long as she's of her
right mind otherwise the court will
choose for her
I think she's of her right mind she's
used to getting her way
she's been bossing people around for
about 86 years and getting away with it
and she's probably also
um wading through that grief and she's
put a leash on you and said you drag me
through this grief in whichever way I
want to go that's not how that works how
that works yeah so Mom I love you
and I'll be happy to help you we're
going to get your money if I'm going to
help you here's the terms you're going
to live in Texas where I'm moving to to
be near the grandbabies and you'll see
your great-grandbabies and we're going
to get your money from Nick and we're
going to put it with a professional
money manager that will help us and
teach us how to create an income so we
can hire some help to take care of you
while I'm at work but you can live in my
home and I will love you and take care
of you I am not coming to Florida if you
don't want to do that those two things
it's okay Mom you're it's your choice
the law says that you are allowed to
make your own decisions and it says I am
too and so I'm going to Texas love to
have you otherwise I'll come see you in
Florida uh when I got some days off
and if you want me to help you set up
some care over there I will but I love
you but I'm sorry I get to choose and I
want if let's say she does choose
Florida
I want your heartbreak to not be that
um
you finally decided that your life had
value too I want your heartbreak to be
my mom chose
a retirement village in another state
over me and her grandkids and her
great-grandkids that's heartbreaking oh
break my heart
but that's a total of like 180 to it's
your job to
completely cancel out your life and live
wherever she tells you to live and do
whatever she tells you to do
um it flip that thing around man flip
that thing around yeah
she does not
have a vote unless you give her one so
take her vote from her
on where Max lives
don't get a vote anymore mom and you
have to say it out loud but you just say
it in your mind just smile and go
you know you don't you don't get to the
side that now and Dave uh just the added
complexity
sometimes that parent says well then you
may just not have access to this money
then whatever and you have to decide is
your soul for sale right yeah yeah
that's
that's perfectly okay because apparently
I didn't have access to start with it
Nick has it yeah Nick's got it the
cousin Nick the cousin don't let your
cousin sell your house or manage your
money
those are randoms or new Ramsay rules I
just made up you just made them up on
the spot deloney Rams are deloni rams
rooms well that's probably pretty good
rules this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Larry is with us in Missouri hi Larry
welcome to the Ramsey Show Dave Ramsey
how are you sir better than I deserve
sir how are you I'd like to meet you in
Chicago in September in person oh come
on we're going to be there doing a smart
conference we'd love to have you well
I'd like to come and I hope you're going
to talk on a topic that's very close to
my life right now number one I'm old
enough to be your grandfather oh wow I
was born in the beginning of the 40s
okay
old enough to be my father but anyway
yeah okay yeah Larry Dave is real oh man
well I know his age I've heard him say
it on the on the radio I'm 20 years
older than date okay anyway I can give
you a real quick uh I'd like to put you
in my shoes if I could
about 11 years old back in 1950 I
watched a movie on black and white TV
and was called a millionaire
and that green has stayed with me all my
lifetime I want to be a millionaire
now that I am and my monthly income
would scare the devil out of you and my
retirement
and I'm trying to set up my estate
because I have no living relatives
anymore
my wife died of cancer nine ten years
ago and I've never remarried we never
had kids she was a teacher I was a
teacher for only 10 years of my life on
the high school level I carry a master's
degree a bachelor's uh
now I've got more money then I know what
to do with any suggestions
okay and so there's no nieces nephews
none none that I've complained wow okay
and we're talking seven eight figures
we're not talking we're not talking
twenty five thousand dollars yeah so if
this has got to be a new one for you
um it's not what I get every week that's
for sure but I don't know if I don't
know but anyway it's it's new to it's
I've never talked to Larry about it so
that's new
um the um
you know we at Ramsey in our Ramsey
Family Foundation While I'm Alive give
to things that we have personal
connection to
uh there are a bazillion things out
there that do Ministries and Charities
that do really good work and do it
efficiently there's a lot of them but
there's more of them than there is money
and so uh instead we pick out something
that we personally one of us in the
Ramsey family has a connection to the
people that are doing the ministry and
what it does and so
uh uh you know if there's something
about the way you grew up or something
about you admire uh this or that you're
you're huge on edging your wife is a
teacher you're here's on education you
want to set up some scholarships uh you
uh uh you know you've spent some time in
foster care so you want to take care of
foster kids I don't know what Larry's
whole story is but there's something
that uh tweaks your heart and that's
where I would suggest you start uh
investigating uh those particular
Ministries or Charities and uh uh you
know we want to leave them a good amount
but we don't leave them so much we ruin
them
uh but on the other hand uh and we want
to make sure they're well operated and
that they actually if their thing is
feeding hungry children that they're
actually feeding hungry children if
um
you know if you wanted to uh find uh
some Ministry or teaching that was
helping people like that TV show helped
you uh you brought that up you know that
kind of a thing you could help them I
don't know but I try to find something
that it it is not it is not necessarily
more valid or more efficient the need
isn't necessarily more holy or less holy
than uh than one but it it the
Difference Maker is is that it does have
some kind of connection to my life or
one of my kids lives or something like
that like my son-in-law uh played
football
D1 quarterback and very involved in
sports was a coach for a long time and
so anything around helping athletes and
uh helping coaches is always going to
get his attention it's always something
he's got a connection to as an example
so that's what I want you to look for
some things like that and spend some of
your time investigating them and you can
start giving to them now yeah there's
something powerful about giving
especially on the front end where you
get to see it you get to see the results
you get to see the smiles you get to see
we started making videos
um in in higher education world I wanted
a donor to see the 18 year old that they
were helping and the students started
making videos to say Hey you helped me
get through and that was a powerful
connection right so I I think that'd be
great another thing I like to do is like
when I get to complaining about
something like man the world just needs
to
I like to find some somebody I can lean
into a little bit that is already
working on that problem right it's just
a dime in the bucket but man it feels it
feels good to say okay I'm contributing
to doing more than just complaining you
know I think the other guy that I think
of is was his first name was Larry too
Larry Stewart was
um uh he was secret Santa from uh
Kansas City I think their first name was
Larry and um we had him on the air
before he passed away but he was at a
diner in north Alabama and was hungry he
was broke and he went into the diner and
said I've got to have some food to
himself and so he said I'm just going to
order and then act like I lost my wallet
and so he ordered and he's eating this
hamburger and the guy that on the diner
kind of figured out what was going on
and uh walked around and reached under
his chair and said hey I think you
dropped this and handed him a 20 bill so
that started Larry Larry became a
multi-millionaire like 100 million or so
and he became secret Santa and during
Christmas he would dress up like Santa
Claus and go out in the streets and hand
out a thousand dollars to somebody and a
thousand dollars somebody just randomly
just be walking down and just whatever
God would just speak to him say that guy
over there and he woke up there and just
hand that guy or knock on somebody's
front door and just hand him a thousand
bucks sure and he gave away tens of
thousands of dollars a secret santa it
became such a thing that the the cops he
had cops got in on it and they would go
with him to protect him and
um and he like after 9-1-1 he walked the
streets of New York you know after
Katrina he walked the streets of uh New
Orleans and uh he was an incredible
incredible giver but ever since that one
guy gave him he said they've got twenty
dollars under that seat it cost me
hundreds of thousands of dollars I said
I've given tried to give that back a
thousand times and uh ten thousand times
and he but that was his story that's not
this Larry story that was that guy's
story and uh but that guy was just
random giving it was just you know walk
up somebody Gas Pump Pump and Gas look
like they need a little help and you
know just little kids in the car look a
little ratty or something give them a
couple thousand bucks and walk off and
and um and it was uh
for about a decade nobody could figure
out who he was and when he got cancer
and they told him he wasn't gonna live
he came out and said who secret Santa
was and he let the reporter at the
Kansas City Star who had been trying to
figure it out for years he let him break
the story as to who it was but it's a
great it's a great story I mean it was
incredible we had him on the air and he
actually started a uh a secret santa
school and you can go and I don't know
if it's still up or not I think it was
like secret santa.com or something and
you could go learn how to do what he was
doing and be randomly generous like that
so but that's fun if you live like no
one else you get to live and give like
no one else and uh so it's pretty cool
there's a lot of fun stuff you could do
with it it doesn't have to be
some stodgy trust to some
dusty University right I mean it can be
it can be really flamboyant and crazy
and wild and fun and and it should be
yeah Malcolm gladwell's got some really
remarkable writings about uh
giving your nine or ten million dollars
to uh a school that has a school that
has eight billion right versus I don't
notice yeah with that five thousand
dollars would do for that family yeah
right exactly change it could change
everything for them right yeah
if I were in your shoes and you're that
you know so he's got to be he says in
his 80s right
um I'd be about the business of doing
that right now I would do something and
figure out a way that become the new
that become the new Saturday crossword
puzzle I'm gonna sit here on my front
porch I'm gonna get out there and change
them live I'm gonna figure out somewhere
give away five thousand dollars in the
next six hours I'm gonna get it a couple
of my knucklehead buddies we're going to
the waffle house and we're gonna start
tipping waitresses and waiters and Cooks
like you have never seen like a thousand
bucks each that's right man go out and
sit in the car and watch them dance oh
yeah I love it works for me it's better
than any movie you're gonna watch I'll
guarantee you and uh yeah that could be
really fun I think that'd be a great way
to spend a Saturday
that puts us out of the Ramsay show in
the books
foreign
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work
that they actually love and create real
amazing relationships Dr John deloney
host of the Dr John deloney Show podcast
and YouTube on the Ramsey network is my
co-host today he's also the author of
the number one bestselling book own your
past change your future and the brand
new book we just launched pre-sale on uh
and you can get a deal on it right now
at ramseysolutions.com that's called
building a non-anxious life Genie is in
New Jersey hi Jeannie how are you
hi Dave and John how are you better than
we deserve what's up
okay so
um I think it's a nervous when I call oh
okay I have a an Audi
um Q5 2018. I just paid it off in my
dead Squall in um February something
happened in April and I found out that I
had a three thousand dollar problem and
I was out of warranty
um that was fixed fast forward to today
and like every time I go um to my side
house so I have to drive up a mountain
and lately I've been smelling um this
burning smell and it kind of scares me
and someone told me it could be like oil
burning in the transmission or something
like that and so um so then I started
thinking like you know do I really need
this car I did pay it off but
um I just thought maybe I should be a
little bit more proactive for once in my
life because um it would crush me if I
had to use like you know
um my emergency fund again when I'm
trying to build it up so I was thinking
should I look into extended warranties
that would protect some of those big
items should I sell it
um you know I did attempt to do that and
they offered me something really low
um
I went to a place called We Buy Any Car
yeah you know why they buy them it's
because they buy them cheap so no that's
probably not the point but I also tried
to sell it privately and um and then you
know people are just offering me saying
it's not worth
um what you're asking I all I really
wanted was about 21 for it but it you
know what's the car worth actually
I think it's worth 19. why why do you
think that
I think it because somebody told me that
I think um
this is incredible Gina you're you're um
your sources of information on all this
whole story sucks so all right um what I
want you to do is hey I want you to go
to the website kbb.com for Kelly
kellybluebook.com and click on private
sale and enter the statistics accurately
on your car the mileage and so on and
that will tell you about what the car is
worth
um and if that says 19 then you would
sell it try to sell it for around 19. it
is paid off and you make what kind of
money
um well with the side hustle I make
about
um
I said I just started it three months
ago I would say about 150 or 160
000 a year
yes okay good very good what do you do
for a living
well I'm a school psychologist in my day
job which is you know the bulk of the
money and so into my side hustle I work
at a psychiatric hospital very good good
very good good use of uh good use of
your knowledge base you're you're
calling and so on very good so um Well
here here's what I'm gonna do if I'm in
your shoes all right I'm gonna fix the
car
take it to a reputable mechanic and tell
him it smells when you go up a hill
and get it fixed
because you don't dislike the car you're
just afraid something's going to happen
to it oh see I heard gee tell me if I'm
wrong because I heard that you are just
looking for ways to get out of this car
because you don't like it
no I do like the car but I just but you
don't even you don't even know if
there's a problem yet like you have it I
mean there could be a dead rat under the
hood could be the smell yeah it could be
something you stepped in but I would
smell it all the time I wouldn't smell
it just going up the hill well it
depends on the size of the road
yeah I I would or it could be somebody
is like cooking oil into their house on
that Hill like who know like you're
making a lot you're doing a lines at
work yeah we need we need to find out
what's really going on with the car okay
yeah
and by the way if it has a five thousand
dollar problem it's not worth twenty one
thousand dollars yeah
yeah that's the other thing wait wait
what if it has a five thousand dollar
repair due
and Kelly Blue Book says it's worth 21.
it's not worth 21. because you have a
five thousand dollar repair due so you
need to go find out what's wrong with
your car hon and then that'll give you
peace and help you make the decision
about what you want to do with the car
but um we're not going to have vague
smells dictate twenty thousand dollar
decisions
that's just that's and we're not gonna
not get the car checked out so we can
sell it and say we didn't know anything
was wrong with it we're not going to do
that either no let's go ahead and have
some integrity and just find out what's
going on with it fix the car and decide
if you want to keep it or not okay you
make good money you got a paid for car
if you don't like the car I'm okay with
you selling it but let's go find out
what's wrong with it because you know
the motivation in this whole
conversation is this is the breakdown
issue and um no you never buy an
extended warranty let me remind folks
how extended warranties work okay 80 or
12 is easy easiest way to 12 of what you
pay for an extended warranty on a car or
on electronic Appliance at Best Buy
which is not the Best Buy if you get an
extended warranty
um
a 12 covers the statistical probability
of the cost of the breakdown
88 percent is additional profit
marketing fees and commissions
this is why car dealers sell extended
warranties they make more on the sale of
the extended warranty in some cases than
they do on the actual profit of the car
so extended warranties are absolutely
horrible mathematics
never buy an extended warranty pretty my
breakdown no it's going to break down
but the statistical probability of the
breakdown and the cost of the the the
parts that are covered by the extended
warranty represent 12 of what you paid
so if you pay two thousand dollars for a
dead gum extended warranty on a car
which people do all the time and finance
it into the car that tells us then that
240 dollars is what you actually covered
you got two hundred and forty dollars
worth of actual probability in the rest
of it when in their pocket to make them
smile I didn't think about also you pay
it off over seven years so they're
making a whole bunch more money on top
of that yeah on top of that you financed
it so you didn't think anything about it
and um got some great stories on
extended warranty over the years but
number one they half the time don't
cover the stuff you thought you were
getting them covered because you have to
look at it when you're doing it and so
you made assumptions about it when
you're buying it don't ever buy extended
warranties but
they're almost pure profit and marketing
cost one more important thing when you
call somebody to talk about challenges
with a car don't lead with I got an Audi
because I thought we were talking about
her belly button in front oh my God I
drive an Audi that's the way you enter
into that conversation
just saying
oh I can't take you anywhere this is the
Ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America we are so
glad you're with us we appreciate you
I'm Dave Ramsey your host Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services neighborhood he's got 19
service Brands Nationwide and a network
of local service pros Molly made Mr
Rooter plumbing and Lawn Pride to name
just a few visit neighborly.com to find
available service providers near you all
right today's question comes from Amanda
in Oregon Amanda writes my husband and I
got married last May at the time I did
not realize he had over 25 thousand
dollars in credit card debt plus a
personal loan I also didn't directly ask
him if he had a bunch of credit card
debt but we did have a conversation
where it made where he made it seem that
we were on the same page
I have a little debt the five thousand
dollar credit card and eight thousand
dollar remaining on my car and I've been
working to get this debt paid off when I
found out about his
at this point do I keep snowballing my
debt or now reconfigure everything and
put my money towards his debt as well oh
Dave this marriage is in trouble already
in trouble already
um
my friend Amanda
number one you got to deal with the
trust issue here
um sounds like you all had a
conversation and he heard what you had
to say about it and he was dishonest by
his silence
and second
yes now that you know it's here this
idea that you're going to pay off your
quote unquote little debt and he needs
to pay off his big debt and you got to
take your money and put it on his debt
y'all are married this is y'all's money
paying off y'all's debt
this is something y'all do together and
that tells me that y'all are married and
y'all are probably doing a decent job so
far being roommates that y'all are not
all in together on this deal at all
yeah it's very very important that you
combine your incomes and combine your
debts
and change your change your uh pronouns
it's you're now French we we
us our not his mine
and
um that's your best route out and that's
going to involve a commitment uh from
him
to extreme honesty from this point
forward and by you to clearly ask
questions
um and the two of you need to be on a
written detailed budget together
where every dollar of your household
income the whole income come into the
house is going to be spent on the every
dollar app
and both of you see where every dollar
is going before the month begins
and both of you are in agreement and
both of you stick to that no secrets no
side jobs no side issues they're side
jobs the money goes right in the top of
the budget just like everything else but
there's no little deal where you've got
this secret Target Fund or he has a
secret gun fund or whatever it is right
I might have had a secret gun fund one
time but I didn't have that in Oregon
they'd have to have a high high five
that's fun yeah that's there's that okay
but so here's and we're going to be
doing the marriage and are the money and
marriage getaway events in Nashville
it's October 19th and 21st
um and guys if you guys want to come to
that there's a few tickets left Rachel
and John are going to be doing a three
day long event with some other outside
speakers coming in a very interesting
lineup and a lot of stuff covered on the
money issue and on the marriage issues
uh and it's a whole Nashville weekend
it's going to be a blast yeah it's gonna
be everything from lessons on uh money
and how to deal with conflict and sex
and intimacy the whole thing we're not
leaving any stone unturned and we've
done some some preliminary calls with
folks who've already bought their
tickets and we're part of the Platinum
purchase and that sold out but
um people aren't interested in having as
much of a Kumbaya experience as they
want to get in and do some hard work and
we also have a
we have a lot of cool fun Nashville
things planned for the weekend so it's
gonna be a blast yeah there's some good
Nashville participation
ramsaysolutions.com event for the money
and marriage event and in your case
um Amanda you guys are going to have to
work really hard to get on the same page
and that's trust that's true and that
trust is built by cooperation and
spending together and lots and lots and
lots of clear no deception communication
and no uh no deceiving by silence either
that's I think that's the most the worst
kind so I mean I almost rather you'll
just lie to my face with your mouth
then just sneakers let me feel like in
my heart we're on the same page yeah
then just sneaky just sneaky like you
know yeah passive aggressive so in this
kind of situation I think the smartest
thing to do would be both of y'all go
pull your credit reports put them on the
table and let's go let's go top to
bottom and I think uh make Amanda feel
better about what's actually out there
because now she's got that little bit of
doubt that would make him if he's just
kind of a clueless I don't know then
everybody can be on the same page yeah
you can't loaf your way through this
yeah you're gonna have to deal with it
every dime of it yeah that's that that's
the only shot you got because if you
guys continue to half butt do this
relationship and half butt do this money
and either one of them is going to work
and that's what you've been doing all
right Elizabeth is with us in Cincinnati
hi Elizabeth how are you
I'm fine how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
uh well
I love the book
and I'll
wait till a couple of years ago well
thank you
and our oldest son is the one who
introduced us to Dave Ramsey
and after we seen Rachel we went home
and we got busy okay and
we are me and my husband both will be
turning 60 next month
and we have seven children who are now
all out the door yay and yeah and we
have really worked really hard
and
we were very late in starting 401k
once we started doing all of our savings
we had a couple of catastrophes in our
house
which we had to Do complete remodels
guts bathroom and kitchen because of
black mold so it wasn't beautification
this was health issues
so goodbye savings
and
at this point we only have
a house payment
one car payment with sixteen hundred
dollars left on it and after covid
my husband took a 10 cut and pay lost
his bonuses and with the remodels that
we had to do we
I budget everything I use spreadsheets I
we use cash allowances but I'm to the
point now
I'm my husband has turned over the
finances to me so I don't want to
disappoint him I want to keep him on the
same track
so my question is
we are late getting our 401K but we have
a hundred thousand
we owe 73 000 on our health her house
will not be paid for until we're 72.
and we have a eight thousand dollar
credit card bill because it's a medical
because our savings was gone
do you have any savings that's not in
the 401K
we have six thousand okay
okay which book did you read
The Total Money Makeover and I've had to
start over yeah
you needed both of you get the book out
because number one he turned the money
over to me no
well I know no no no no no don't don't
well me no just know no the two of you
need to sit down and make these
decisions together you don't get to
carry this by yourself superhero you
don't get that privilege the two of you
need to make these decisions and carry
this weight and he doesn't get to bow
out like a coward and say oh whatever
I'll just he didn't get to do that
either no so what does he make
he makes 113. what do you make
that's your nice our son passed away I
kind of
are you still Mike yes I am are they
paying you
none one of them does good okay so you
get the book back out and start working
back through the dead snowball leave
your 401k alone get the stupid credit
card paid off the stupid car paid off
and then let's build an emergency fund
and then let's put 15 of our income away
and then let's start working on paying
off the house and both of you need to do
everything you can to maximize your
income and I want your debt free house
and everything in five years you can do
that
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us all month long we're
giving away cash you can win one of our
500 weekly prizes or the grand prize of
three thousand dollars entered daily at
ramseysolutions.com giveaway while
you're there you can pre-order Dr John
deloney's brand new book building a
non-anxious life you'll learn the six
daily choices to break free from a life
spinning out of control plus when you
pre-order today for just twenty dollars
you get 75 worth of free bonus items
helps John helps you everybody gets a
deal I think everybody's winning
building a non-anxious life
ramseysolutions.com
store Ryan is in birming ham hey Ryan
welcome to the Ramsay show
what's going on hey what's up
hey man so I just had a couple of
questions for you uh
uh I recently have a quit gambling and
uh I'm kind of in the hole right now and
I just need some advice
what kind of gambling were you doing
uh specifically uh double deck Blackjack
um and a fair amount of Poker Texas
Hold'em online
uh no sir
um no sir how much have you lost
uh I'd say about a year ago I had like a
four day stretch where I won and lost
about six figures
okay
so you recently quit gambling tell me
about that what's that mean
and my dad's income is great I just keep
putting myself in the same uh the same
hole yeah
you've had a gambling problem and you
just decided I quit and that's it that
that's all you've done so would you
backfill that hole with
um man I I am behind on Grant uh three
Corvette three car payments uh I owe
probably about twenty five hundred
dollars to friends of mine and uh right
now I'm just kind of living check to
check
but you quit gambling 60 days ago so
what six months ago six months ago what
have you done in the meantime that has
continued to make your your life
problems so challenging
too a loan from a friend for about 10
grand and then I was paying him back
payments after I'd lost that uh large
sump of money and uh so I've been kind
of paying him back when I can
um and then my student loans just said
I've got about eighty four thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt what
do you mean that's about uh probably
around I'd say I'm in sales so I'd say
this year I'm on track to make about
150. okay and you're single
yes sir okay how old are you
I'm 22.
what have you
been going to Gamblers Anonymous or are
you seeing a therapist or anything
uh I just I had my first uh meeting with
a counselor a Christian counselor on
Wednesday Good Friday another meeting
next week oh okay good I appreciate it
that's what that's what I was worried
about okay good yeah my dad he's a
pastor and uh man he acts like he
doesn't have two dimes to rub together
but I mean he'll he'll definitely retire
a millionaire for sure uh and it's it's
hard to talk about my finances with him
uh because he'd be so so angry with me
uh you know and so you know I kind of
just accepted the fact that I needed
help and good
um I'm upset with myself so time to make
some changes for sure an important part
to get an important part of getting well
is finding
um this word gets thrown around
culturally so
um I don't mean in the uh
never tells me the truth kind of way um
it doesn't hold me accountable kind of
way but part of getting well is finding
a safe person or safe people that you
can actually say hey I'm not all right
and I've dug myself a mask and um
sometimes our dads aren't that sometimes
our moms aren't that sometimes our
spouses aren't that it doesn't it
doesn't relieve us to the fact that we
gotta go find people and I'm proud of
you for doing that man yeah that's very
important part of this conversation Ryan
now now that you've done that what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
move from chaos
which this out of control feeling that
an addiction gives you and the chaos
that results in your finances and the
chaos that results in your career and
the chaos that results in your
relationships you're trying to move
wisely from chaos to order
you're trying to bring order to these
different areas of your life that's at
least what you should be doing but it
sounds like that's what you're asking to
do and I'm proud of you for that as well
so the thing we're going to do with your
money is we're going to put you on a
very strict budget where you don't get
to do anything except pay off debt and I
want you to list your debts smallest to
largest and start paying them in that
order and I don't want you going out to
eat I don't want you in a bar and I
don't want you doing anything except
working
and uh getting these debts cleaned up
did you say your three car payments
behind or you have three cars
oh no on three car payments behind uh I
I my next check hits tomorrow uh can you
bring it current with that check
um
um so my rent I I spent about 1500 a
month and bills uh and you know now that
I'm behind how much are the car payments
uh it's 259. okay so you need 750 what's
your check gonna be
uh it's gonna be about after it's
actually about 987 it's my draw so I'm
on a two thousand dollar draw and then I
get my commission at the end of the
month
um okay you have any money in your
account now much I have about a hundred
bucks to my name right now okay I want
you to take care and you haven't paid
the rent yet
no sir how much is your rent
uh it's about a thousand bucks okay I
want you to call your landlord and tell
him that you're going to pay him two
rent payments at the end of the month
that you can't pay him right now because
you got to keep your car from being
repoed okay sir and you call him before
when you get off the phone and tell him
that and he's not going to do anything
he's not gonna like it but you're gonna
pay him two payments at the first of the
month because you got enough coming in
to do that because you're making good
money you're just not made but it all
comes in at the end of the month right
yes sir okay and you only can do two
things right now with this with this
check eat
and get the car caught up because at 90
days they're gonna pick the car up man
you're at the repo point they are not
gonna screw around you're gonna look up
there's not gonna be no car in the
driveway and a wrecker running down your
street that's right where you are yeah
who do you owe this money to uh
you talking about the gambling no the uh
the car payment
oh uh uh Federal Credit Union okay
uh so that's a local credit union in
your area
oh yes sir uh I think they're based out
of Biloxi call them and see if you can
give them two payments out of this check
tomorrow and give you a little bit of
money to cut is your is your electric
bill behind too
uh wait what was that is your
electricity and water behind as well
um so I have a roommate and he's taking
care of that and I was kind of filtering
in where I'm at and uh he's taking care
of some of the utilities I might have to
pay him back uh okay but uh all right
because here's the here's the rule
you're looking for
okay the food
shelter
clothing which you probably don't need
any of transportation and utilities
everyone else Waits until those are
current
food you eat not out to eat groceries
baloney hot dogs beans and rice
okay
food
utilities shelter which is rent and
transportation so you get this car
straightened up you get your landlord
straightened up you get your roommate
straightened up on the utilities before
we talk about paying anybody
I don't care who they are you got to
take care of your four walls of survival
before you move on to the next thing
does that make sense to you
it does absolutely it is the fastest way
for you to get to these other people now
once your car is current what will you
owe on it
uh my balance is about 12 goods and what
do you owe you had ten thousand dollars
on a gambling debt and what else
um I own I owe 900 to a friend of mine
uh who wanted me some cash what else
1500 uh 1500 to a firm okay and your and
your check at the end of the month is
going to be what 10 grand five eight
grand
roughly it fluctuates between about 8
500 yeah so you're gonna be able to
clear up almost everyone but the big one
and your car
and by Christmas the big one and the car
are going to be cleared up no debt you
feel the chaos leaving your life feel
the order happening this is what we're
doing very precise follow this exactly
hold on we're gonna get you with a
counselor in your area a financial coach
we're going to furnish it free we want
to be part of you changing your life
young man hold on
foreign
[Music]
12 25 anxiety weighs down the heart but
a kind word cheers it up
Cory ten Boom said
God takes our sins the past present and
future and dumps them in the sea and
puts up a sign that says no fishing
allowed
oh you gotta love Corey open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Elise is in Phoenix hi Elise
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi gentlemen thank you for taking my
call today sure how can we help
so my husband and I are currently on
baby step two
um we have roughly paid off about 40
Grand since 2020. well also cash flowing
a wedding a bachelor's degree and a
high-risk pregnancy and we have about
eighteen thousand dollars left y'all
been busy
yeah uh since having our son in November
we have had a whirlwind of the year
um we lost my mother-in-law to cancer in
March we lost my grandfather in June and
we lost my husband's grandmother on
Monday oh my goodness wow yeah so
um we've been handling my
mother-in-law's estate there was no will
or trust so we've been hunting down
individual accounts with my husband and
his brother listed as beneficiaries and
we're starting to receive some of that
money
um we've been treating our situation as
a combination of storm mode along with
baby step two
um because you never know as like her
medical bills and things are going to
come in so we're trying to make sure
that we have a stash set aside you're
not you're not liable for her medical
bills okay good
um her estate is
yeah about the money that's in her name
has to be used for those before you get
to take it as heirs but um but you can't
Europe not personally liable for her
medical bills
no we're just the ones that are handling
that yeah so you don't need a storm mode
because your personal finances aren't
affected by her situation beautiful so
that was my first question because we
have we received an annuity from her and
currently a 30 thousand dollars in the
bank and that would take that was a
benefit you were the beneficiary of the
annuity
yes okay that's your money that's clear
of the estate you don't have to worry
about it
so we can go ahead and use that for baby
step two and you can use that for
anything you want to personally
awesome
um so we'll probably handle that today
uh the second step we just transferred
about seventy seven thousand dollars in
single stocks into our names and then we
have an inherited IRA and an inherited
401K that will be split between my
husband and his brother once we're ready
for it
um with losing everyone we're just
trying to cling to stability and so what
we were wondering is if it was a wise
decision to liquidate some of those
single stocks for a good down payment on
a house next year
um I think you're too much in the middle
of the fire to worry about a house right
now don't do anything I think right now
you just can't clean up and get to calm
clean up and get to get to sit and then
just sit in this a little while probably
next year if you have extra money above
your emergency fund and you're 100 debt
free we'll talk about a house yeah
that's probably exactly
but please please please please please
don't spend money that
you don't have yet and even these
inherited whatevers if she's got bills
to pay you're gonna have to go to pay
off the off the estate and you're going
to feel like these companies stole from
you they didn't they just need their
payments let me let me stop you a second
okay there's two categories of money in
her estate
okay there's stuff that named you a
beneficiary if there's life insurance
and you're a beneficiary your husband
that comes straight to you that is not
in her estate that annuity comes
straight to you as a beneficiary it's
not in her estate those stocks
are not yours
that checking account even if your
husband's name on it is not yours
that money has to be used to pay her
medical bills
okay before you clear up anything
okay perfect so unless it came to you
and it caused it was in or your husband
because it was in a named beneficiary it
has to be used to pay the bills of the
estate now an inherited IRA did it have
a name to beneficiary on it
yes okay
same thing then that is outside of the
estate it is not subject to her other
bills but that stock you're talking
about those checking accounts those are
you got to keep that separate over to
the side until the bills are cleared
okay you see the difference
yes because those weren't in your name
the other the other stuff was named
directly not you your husband named
directly to him so
um I think it's going to be worth your
all's while to spend 500 or a thousand
dollars with a with a probate attorney
to help you sort through this and do
this properly because you're gonna have
to file some of this stuff with the
judge
okay and uh you're gonna you shouldn't
be a huge attorney's fee I wouldn't pay
much more than that but 500 a thousand
bucks should get that probated and you
know get the stuff transfer was there a
car as an example
yes yeah so you can't transfer that
title without without a court order
okay so because you can't sign her name
she's dead right you have to sign you
have to sign on behalf of her and the
court has to give you permission to do
that so
yeah you guys need to get an attorney
and that'll help you separate the things
we're talking about but When the Smoke
Clears on this if the medical bills
aren't too high it sounds like you're
going to be debt free with a nice Nest
Egg above your emergency fund and yes
maybe this time next year I'm going to
be thinking about uh or after the first
of the year I'm going to be thinking
about getting a car or getting a house
rather and being debt free and having
the emergency fund in place before you
do any of that
good question did God help any listener
who doesn't have a will yes gosh get a
will get a will get a will get a will it
does not increase your probability of
death
no but it is not gonna make it you're
not gonna make it you're gonna die
you need a will go to mama bear legal
forms and get a will go to a local state
planning attorney get a will but
somewhere get you a will you're not that
expensive it's not that complicated
um yes it's weird talking about dying
but guess what you're gonna die I'll
help you with it you're not gonna make
it get a will
please save all this problem listen to
that sweet girl lost three family
members in the period of just a short
few weeks and now has to deal with this
with and doesn't they're out like a
treasure hunt looking for accounts
when they should be sitting on the front
porch hugging each other telling stories
about how much they loved you yeah
instead yeah they're combing through
your stuff
detector in the backyard looking for the
coffee can where you hid the money
get a will get a will
wow that's bad
and right before you get a will get a
budget
that was a bad segue but yeah maybe one
of the worst Segways ever ever ever ever
ever ever hey we're doing a free every
dollar budgeting webinar with Rachel
Cruz August 15th next week if you want
to watch this webinar with Rachel
teaching you how to run the every dollar
software the every dollar app properly
with an irregular income working the
baby steps in great detail she's going
to do that it's completely free Jay did
one yesterday with ten thousand people
in attendance it was pretty amazing
so Rachel's is next uh Tuesday I guess
it is August 15th whatever that is it's
two that's that's right Tuesday I think
anyway August 15th next week uh for most
of you listening go to everydollar.com
budgeting and you can sign up for this
free webinar and uh get get get the
every dollar app start working because
every dollar is by far the best
budgeting app out there not there's not
even close second I know people think
about this or that let me just tell you
then we've got tens of millions of
people doing this
so be sure to check this out and if you
need help like I said ten thousand were
with Jade yesterday we can handle it
August 15th we're gonna have some more
scheduled over the next 60 days with
George and Rachel and Jade but this
coming week is Rachel August 15th
everydollar.com
budgeting and um
that'll get you going for sure without a
doubt so uh Dr John deloney good show
today thank you so the I guess the the
key takeaways are
pre-buy my book
get a will
get every dollar app
foreign
people think John deloney that's the
next word they think that's what that
guy Austin Ben James Zack and Andrew are
in the booth the booth dudes did a great
job today I'm Dave Ramsey your host will
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]